[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN MCMAHAN: Hi,
I'm Ben McMahan.
I'm a tech lead on the
Google Doodle team.
I have a quick question.
How many of you have ever
played a Doodle game?
So quite a few of you.
Well, making a game
on the Google homepage
has some interesting
unique challenges.
So let's look at the homepage.
First, like every kind of
person, from every country,
with every kind of interest
and screen configuration
you can think of, goes
to the Google homepage.
And second of all, they
didn't come to play a game.
They came to do a search,
like if my rash is contagious
or something.
[LAUGHTER]
So we're inherently
distracting right here,
and so we still have to
do right by the user.
So we've learned
a lot of lessons.
Like, one obvious one is
go straight to your game.
So a couple of years ago,
we had this idea, oh, we'll
let them pick a team
and have their score go
to some global score
count for that team.
But there are two things
wrong that we found out.
One is half our users
left on this screen,
because they had no idea
what they were going to get.
And the other problem--
and we could have known this
just looking at YouTube data--
is one of them
holds a cat, so we
should have known
all of them would
have picked that one anyways.
[LAUGHTER]
So to help us learn
all these lessons,
I've come up with
a bunch of F-words.
Because people take
F-words very seriously.
So the first one
is to be friendly.
And by this, I mean
non-gamer friendly.
So you've got to
keep things simple,
go with paradigms
people already know.
It's interesting.
When you make your own game,
you end up playing it a lot.
And you get really
good at your game,
way more than a user will,
being only able to play it
for one day, right?
So you've got to anchor yourself
with a lot of play tests
and user studies
[? with ?] people
who have never played the game--
and even better, if you can
make it a diverse set of people,
outside of your normal
demographic comfort zone.
I was lucky last year,
I playtested a lot
with my five-year-old.
And I was instantly able to tell
exactly how much dexterity you
need to play any of the games.
Next, you have,
like, five seconds
tops to do something enjoyable.
It could be just a
really cute character,
or the first hill you go over,
something amazing happens.
If you think about it,
in our context, people
after about five seconds are
like, no, wait, wait, wait,
I really do need
to do that search.
I'm going to go back
and go do that search.
And that's great,
but they shouldn't
feel like they wasted
their five seconds.
They should have gotten
something out of it.
Next, it should be fun to fail.
A lot of games have a challenge.
Otherwise it's not as fun.
But that also means
a lot of people
are going to fail when
you think about everyone
playing your game.
So just make sure
that that's fun.
A lot of times, we just
make something funny happen.
Like, for example, in
this game, the watermelon
does squish the strawberry.
And on the opposite side,
when people are doing well,
you know, go into a frenzy mode.
Reward them.
Make them feel special.
So if they hit something
perfectly three times,
just go nuts.
I think NBA Jam did
this perfectly with its
you're-on-fire mechanic.
And a quick word
on tutorials-- so
we do in-game tutorials
because of a previous lesson.
But we also try to
do it without text.
And this is a great
confirmation that you've made
a simple and friendly game.
Because if a non-gamer
can come to your game
and learn how to play
it without any text,
you've probably kept it
simple and intuitive.
Now, we don't always succeed.
Last year, we had
this Halloween game
where you had to draw
a symbol over a ghost
to get it to disappear.
And we just couldn't find a way
with user studies to do that.
So these are more goals than
rules, but still a useful one.
And our final F-word kind of
over-arches all the F-words--
is feelings.
And there's this great
quote by Maya Angelou.
You know, people will
forget what you say.
They'll even forget
what you did.
But they'll never forget
how you made them feel.
So it's a good idea
to just go over
every screen, every
choice, every challenge,
and just ask yourself,
how am I making
our users feel right now?
And you'll find some low-hanging
fruit to improve your game.
So in conclusion,
if you want to make
a game that can appeal to,
say, like a billion people,
don't forget to encourage
your team to use more F-words.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]